the planned final flight of a 1950s era
military cargo plane has ended in
disaster surveillance video shows the
c-130 aircraft banking then plunging to
the ground yesterday it exploded into
flames on a busy Georgia highway all
nine crew members aboard were killed it
had just taken off from Savannah Hilton
Head International Airport and was
headed for retirement
mark Strassmann is near the scene
outside Savannah mark good morning
good morning the investigation and the
debris cleanup here will go on for weeks
and the big question is why why a
military cargo plane crashed into the
median of the highway behind me narrowly
avoiding traffic warehouses and a nearby
gas station God Jesus God only the tail
remained intact of the c-130 cargo plane
after it crashed
late Wednesday morning first responders
including passing drivers desperately
searched through the heavy smoke for
survivors roger best was working nearby
all of my co-workers we all stopped what
we were doing we ran and got as close as
we could but could tell there was
nothing nobody could do the Puerto Rico
National Guard plane took off from
Savannah Hilton Head International
Airport shortly before 11:30 a.m.
surveillance video from a nearby
business captured what happened next the
plane Bank left before nose diving and
spiraling into the ground
seconds later a fireball and black smoke
went shooting into the sky the military
aircraft was more than 60 years old one
of the oldest c-130s still flying
it belonged to Puerto Rico's 156th
airlift wing which helped with relief
efforts following last year's
devastating hurricane season I've been
to Puerto Rico many times it was the
same plane behind President Trump during
his visit to Puerto Rico following
Hurricane Maria the aircraft flew to
Savannah for maintenance last month and
on Wednesday it was bound for Arizona to
be retired it's the second time in less
than a year that a version of the c-130
flying for the US military has been
involved in a deadly crash
last July a Marine Corps kc-130 crashed
in rural Mississippi killing all 16
service members on board the military
Times published an investigation last
month it reported that the number of
accidents involving manned military
aircraft between 2013 and 2017 spiked
40% 40% the names of those killed in
yesterday's crash Gale will be released
as soon as their families have been
notified mark it's tough to look at that
video because the people on board knew
this was not going to end well thank you
very much